[Musik]
und damit herzlich willkommen hier heute
zu einer neuen Folge Skyblock mit Luca
meine Damen und Herren wir dürfen
allerdings gar nicht lange Zeit
verlieren ich habe mal wieder extrem
viel auf der To-Do-Liste und wir fangen
direkt damit an dass ich den
Cobblestone Generator zurück benötige
ich werde das einfach mal so machen dass
ich äh kann ich das hier abbauen nee ich
könnte es glaube ich so machen da sollte
noch nichts anfangen zu brennen indem
ich nämlich einfach mal hier vorne ein
Loch Grabe dann das Wasser hier runter
fließen lasse da geht jetzt natürlich
direkt nach unten allerdings fließt es
dann nicht hier rüber doch sollte doch
dann müssen wir glaube ich das hier
wieder zu bauen hier vorne den abbauen
und hier drunter den auch abbauen so
dass es hier runter geht und wenn wir
den jetzt wieder hinsetzen und wieder
abbauen dann sollte das klappen genau
dann können wir den hier noch abbauen
können hier die Lava hinsetzen und haben
dann einen neuen Cobblestone Generator
den benötigen wir auch denn ich benötige
ein wenig Steine weil wir für die
heutige Episode natürlich wieder ein
bisschen was vom Ecken das sieht schon
geil aus hier so ne
finde ich richtig schön hier mit diesen
Kisten da vorne hier sieht man so ein
bisschen Lava ein bisschen Licht da
hinten geht die Sonne unter hier ist
unsere egal ich will nicht ablenken wir
haben für heute eine Menge Sachen vor
ich benötige Cobblestone weil ich
dahinten auf der Insel wo dieser
Mangobaum ist da vorne das werde ich
jetzt heute mal komplett abbauen
weil mich stört das
ich kann den Sonnenuntergang gar nicht
richtig sehen mir wurde zwar auch das
hier geschrieben und wegen Luca lass das
doch da brauchst du nicht das stehen und
mir wurde auch nicht nur das geschrieben
sondern auch das hier von wegen man soll
nicht das komplette Biom abbauen weil er
dann wieder was bauen kann ist mir
allerdings relativ egal ich will dass
das schön aussieht und ich brauche jetzt
nicht unbedingt so ein Mango nach vorne
um da irgendwas zu bauen meine Pizza ist
kaputt perfekt und was ich auch nicht
brauche ist ähm irgendwie dass das da
stehen bleibt oder so oder dass ich
etwas anderes mache weil wir haben ja
die Zeit und ich möchte dass es schön
aussieht und mir wurde auch geschrieben
habe ich in der letzten Folge schon
erwähnt dass da oben tatsächlich auch
Holz drin ist was wir natürlich immer
gut gebrauchen können weil unsere Bäume
die sich hinter mir befinden tatsächlich
einfach nicht wachsen
ich weiß nicht was mit denen los ist
wir machen mal eben fixe timelaps
während ich das hier abbaue vielleicht
ist dann Baum gewachsen
[Musik]
so
dann war komplett abgebaut ich habe
anderthalb sechs Bruchsteine es ist
tatsächlich kein einziger ein einziger
Baum gewachsen ich ähm weiß nicht warum
aber es hat auf jeden Fall noch
angefangen zu regnen das heißt äh das
Licht Level ist auch noch mal ein
Stückchen niedriger geworden das heißt
es wird tendenziell eher nur noch
schwieriger das hier was weg aber
hoffentlich haben wir zum Ende des
Videos mal so ein bisschen
Holz es ist schon gruselig ne wenn man
mal überlegt guck mal wir sind ganz
alleine hier auf dieser Insel
und Mitten also um uns rum klar sind
noch andere kleine Inseln aber wir haben
keine Tiere wir haben nicht mal Monster
aber das ist das Ziel für heute denn ich
möchte heute auf jeden Fall nicht nur
habe ich heute noch vor insgesamt sieben
challenges abzuschließen weil wir in der
letzten Folge glaube ich gar keine
hatten sondern ich möchte auch noch
heute die Monster fahren bauen ich werde
nicht die Monster fahren bauen können
ich eigentlich Vorhaben weil
ich darf für deutlich mehr Holz benötige
und das wie gesagt kriegen wir nicht hin
hier wächst er einfach nichts allerdings
können wir eine Plattform zumindest
schon mal bauen damit wir so ein
bisschen Skelette haben um Knochenmehl
zu bekommen weil ihr seht auch unsere
Weizen haben die gibt nichts voran
natürlich klar das ist alles so ein
bisschen Schneeballeffekt ne wenn wir
jetzt mehr Holz haben können wir auch
mehr setzen Dinge anpflanzen das heißt
wir kriegen wiederum mehr Holz und auch
beim Weizen wenn wir einen Weizen
angepflanzt haben ist natürlich nicht so
krass wie wenn wir dann irgendwann 10
haben dann wachsen die alle und dann
können wir direkt aus den zehn wieder 20
neue so mäßig anpflanzen das geht
bisschen schneller deshalb habe ich so
richtig verstanden was das hier bringen
soll äh da ist jetzt nichts an Essen
aber na ja die Mauern kann ich hier
vorne immer hinsetzen aber das zumindest
noch mal so ein bisschen abgesperrt ähm
genau ich würde allerdings sagen bevor
ich nach da hinten gehe weil ich will
das ja heute komplett abbauen damit ich
den schönen Blick auf den
Sonnenuntergang habe bevor ich da hinten
hin gehe ja dann will ich eigentlich das
Tag ist weil ich jetzt nicht bei Nacht
und bei Regen da hinten laufen will weil
da könnte ich ja theoretisch was bauen
von daher fangen wir erstmal mit was
anderem an was ich heute geplant habe
und zwar dass ich erstmal ein paar mich
darum kümmere denn es gibt eine
Challenge die lautet 20
bruchsteintreppen das heißt ich mache
hier insgesamt 20 Treppen Zack und noch
mal Zack und dann haben wir insgesamt
[Musik]
20 Bruchstein Treppen keine Ahnung wofür
wie benötigen allerdings kann ich das
auf meiner Liste hier schon mal
abarbeiten was wir auch noch haben sind
steindruckplatten dafür benötigen wir
allerdings Holz was wir verbrennen
müssen können wir das hier wenn wir
irgendwas als Brennmaterial verwenden
ich will jetzt nicht mehr reinpacken
weil davon habe ich schon so wenig
allerdings glaube ich brauchen wir
tatsächlich äh da vorne könnte ich mir
eben noch eine Fackel hinsetzen die kann
ich nicht weil ich fast keine mehr habe
und die muss hier bleiben damit der hier
im Bereich hier ein bisschen ausleuchtet
ist ähm ich brauche tatsächlich ein
bisschen was zum Brennen deswegen kann
ich das nicht machen was wir allerdings
machen können sind Stein Druckplatten
die können wir auch nicht machen weil
wir für Stein Druckplatten ebenfalls
normale Steine benötigen und nicht
Bruchsteine dann können wir allerdings
auf jeden Fall die zehn Schilder machen
wir müssen nämlich zehn schilderkraft
wie kriege ich hier draußen
ist das jetzt so wir brauchen wirklich
Holz ne
das kannst du ja nicht ausdenken wie wir
am Arsch sind nee okay ich glaube dann
haben wir tatsächlich keine andere Wahl
als wirklich nach da hinten zu laufen
ich werde allerdings alles wieder was
ich am besten nicht verlieren sollte mal
hier lassen ich werde mir noch mal eben
kurz eine neue Spitzhacke machen und
eine Axt habe ich dabei ich glaube mehr
benötige ich nicht ich werde noch ein
bisschen was hier lassen nämlich die
Stufen und dann können wir mal gucken ob
das dann vielleicht gleich ein bisschen
besser geworden ist das Problem ist dass
es da hinten jetzt sehr dunkel werden
wird aber dann macht er euren Bildschirm
halt einfach ein bisschen aber ich kann
jetzt auch keine Fackel mitnehmen weil
wir haben keine Kohle und die Fackeln
die ich habe die müssen da hinten bei
den Bäumen stehen so dass die ein
bisschen mehr Licht haben wenn ich jetzt
allerdings gerade schon drüber laufen
kann ich euch schon mal sagen wo ich die
Monster fahren möchte die wird nämlich
genau hier stattfinden sie muss laut
Challenge 24 Blöcke entfernt sein von
unserer Hauptinsel und äh ja das ist ja
eigentlich ganz gut weil wir haben jetzt
schon relativ viel gebaut
großen Fledermäuse
warum fliegen hier Fledermäuse rum
die sind aber keine Monster oder
ich meinte aber ich habe Bruchsteinen
Stufen gebaut das heißt eigentlich kann
ich nichts bauen es ist trotzdem sehr
sehr gruselig hier bin ich ganz ehrlich
jetzt sehen wir da hinten die Inseln
sind auch hier ja da hinten da sehen was
auch da sind auf jeden Fall auch Fackeln
was mir auch geschrieben wurde aber das
hier Luca da sind Zelte ne hier ist ein
Zelt und da ist angeblich wolle dran das
heißt daraus könnten uns im Bett craften
ich will allerdings noch da hinten weil
das sind ja böse Gegner und ich will
nicht dass sie mir irgendwie einen
Strich durch die Rechnung machen und
dann konzentrieren uns jetzt erstmal
so einen halbenstein konzentrieren uns
jetzt erstmal hier drauf es wird
allerdings schon heller sieht man hier
also die Sonne geht auch wenn man es
jetzt gerade nur erahnen kann ich werde
das hier vorne mal abbauen ich weiß
nicht was ich damit soll allerdings
wurde mir wie gesagt geschrieben dass da
oben Holz drin ist okay das ist
wahrscheinlich das Holz ne
was ist das man groben Stamm ja okay
daraus können wir uns auf jeden Fall
auch noch was machen die können wir zur
Not auch verbrennen weil mir auch ja
geschrieben wurde dass dieses grüne was
hier runter hängt tatsächlich nur ein
Setzling ist das heißt da kann
eigentlich nichts mit passieren wenn ich
den abbaue das ist jetzt nichts giftiges
oder so und wir können damit im Zweifel
auch sogar was anpflanzen zack haben wir
einen großen Keimlinge okay ich weiß
jetzt nicht was Unterschied zwischen
Keimling und setzen ist aber gut laufen
wir hier an der Seite hoch ich würde
sagen ich blende euch mal eben kurze
timelaps eigentlich das hier abbaue ein
bisschen länger dauern wird
[Musik]
so meine Damen und Herren ich habe hier
vorne alles abgebaut die beiden Sachen
werden demnächst denke ich mal hoffe ich
auch noch mal die spawnen ich habe auch
schon locker 30 40 bruchsteinstufen
abgebaut von dem Weg wir müssen gleich
dann noch mal nachzählen weil die
Monster fahren ja 24 Blöcke entfernt
sein soll von unserer Hauptinsel das
sind hier gerade natürlich aktuell
deutlich mehr als 24 Blöcke aber die
Plattform soll auch eine gewisse Größe
haben und auch das Potential bieten dass
ich auf Dauer dort
etwas größeres im Monat kann eine
bessere Monsterfarm weil aktuell habe
ich einfach noch nicht die Ressourcen
ich habe noch nicht das Holz und diese
ganzen Falltüren machen es ist
tatsächlich kein einziger Baum gewachsen
es ist übel entspannt allerdings seht
ihr schon hier unten ich habe 26 Mango
Stämme deswegen können wir daraus
tendenziell eigentlich erstmal was
anderes machen und zwar das als
Heizmittel benutzen für insgesamt 10
normale Steine wir brauchen zehn Steine
Druckplatten wie macht man eine
Druckplatte ich kann mal kurz gucken wie
man das mit normalen äh wie man das
theoretisch mit Bruchstein machen würde
nee nee sie überhaupt
so so okay eine das heißt ich brauche 20
Steine okay gut dann müssen wir auf
jeden Fall ordentlich was rein knallen
zwei haben wir schon das heißt 18 Stück
müssen noch dann können wir daraus
wartet was mir noch mal kurz schauen ja
okay wir müssen dann insgesamt wirklich
20 Steine haben um die 20
steindruckplatten Challenge abschließen
zu können zehn holzdruckplatten müssen
wir auch noch hinkriegen da ist
allerdings die Sache dass wir das jetzt
theoretisch aus diesem Mangrovenholz
Brettern machen können weil die benötige
ich jetzt nicht unbedingt oder sollte
ich vielleicht eichenholzbretter nehmen
ich weiß es nicht ich finde Eiche
deutlich schöner aber dieses Mango Zeug
ich meine dass sie hinsetzen
ich finde das jetzt nicht so schön das
sieht aus wie so ein sieht irgendwie so
rot aus kann also logisch das soll ja
auch wahrscheinlich rot sein aber egal
ich mache das jetzt einfach mal hier mit
wir brauchen nämlich insgesamt zehn
holzdruckplatten
gut machen wir jetzt mal zack
ich weiß nicht ob das sinnvoll war dass
ich jetzt meine ganzen Holzbretter dafür
verbraucht aber allerdings habe ich halt
fünf von diesem großen Keimlingen kann
ich die Kamera oh oh hi moin Meister wir
haben Baum
wisst ihr was ich machen ein kleines
Experiment ich nehme einfach mal ein
Erdblock und habe ich noch die Stufen ja
ich habe bruchsteinstufen wir machen das
jetzt einfach mal ich teste das jetzt
mal wenn ich das theoretische vorne
hinsetzte zack machen wir hier ein
Erdblock äh perfekt ich glaube wieder
super machen wir hier ein Erdblock hin
und setzen hier einfach mal einen großen
Keimling drauf und schau mal ob das
Ganze funktioniert wenn da jetzt noch
einen großen Baum wechsel dann können
wir das theoretisch nutzen um hier
außenrum so ein paar Bäume zu bauen so
dass wir uns zumindest nicht so fühlen
als wären wir mitnehmen Niemandsland
aber gut ich speicher das erstmal muss
Teppich habe ich auch noch
schöner Mann Teppich
können wir ja theoretisch benutzen um so
ein bisschen so als Fußabtreter wenn man
von der außerhalb kommt kommt man dann
hin dann trifft man sich erstmal so
durch die Füße ab und hier vorne den
anderen Sprache ich mir glaube ich oder
machen wir so eine große Fußmatte man
großen Wurzeln ich weiß auch nicht was
damit machen soll sieht nicht so schön
aus kann man vielleicht
auch als Deko Element irgendwann noch
mal benutzen vielleicht hier so an den
Ecken ich weiß nicht verbinden sich die
aber perfekt verbinden die sich damit ja
verbinden soll
wenn man Fackel draufsetzt das dann
schöner aus
irgendwie ich habe noch nicht so ganz
die besten Ideen gerade weil wir glaube
ich primär einfach ja perfekt das sieht
super aus jetzt habe ich nicht nur eine
Spitzhacke ich glaube einfach es liegt
daran weil wir noch nicht an der
fichtenholzinsel waren weil ich noch
nicht meine meine Fichte abgebaut habe
ich liebe Fichtenholz natürlich kann man
so viel machen in Minecraft allerdings
würde ich sagen dass wir das hier
erstmal so stehen ähm ich speicher die
Sachen hier erstmal ganz kurz drin bevor
ihr noch irgendwas passiert das ist
fertig elf Stück haben wir jetzt okay
wir haben sogar ein Zuviel das halt nie
wenn man zu wenig
oh nein
mit dem Brettern geht er doch geht
wieso geht das nicht mit den
eichenholzbrettern vorhin naja okay wir
kümmern uns zwei Bäume sind gewachsen
okay perfekt das heißt wir und es hört
auf zu regnen meine Damen und Herren das
Glück kommt zurück wir haben immer erst
so ein bisschen Pech und dann kommt das
Flugzeug allerdings geht doch ich habe
jetzt immer richtig Angst von den
Phantom weil die haben mich vorhin auch
schon gekillt ich möchte allerdings
nicht wie bereits gesagt jetzt schon in
die in diese komische Festung da hinten
gehen weil ich Angst habe dass die mich
auch ein bisschen Boxen werden ich werde
jetzt erstmal den Baum hier abbauen dann
direkt 96 den hinsetzen und hoffen dass
ich auch hier noch mehr sitzen Dinge
rausbekomme sollte allerdings möglich
sein wir haben jetzt mittlerweile auch
hier vorne setzen das ist auch gewachsen
sehr geil okay das können wir auch
gleich abbauen ich setze hier vorne
erstmal wieder neuen Setzling hin und
werde auch immer eben kurz den Baum
abbauen so dass wir dann da vorne auch
direkt neu setzen hinsetzen können
beziehungsweise erstmal die Bruchstein
Stufen hier außen rum zack zack zack
zack zack zack zack zack zack zack zack
zack
zack zack zack zack ich gehe hier auf
Nummer Sicher sicher damit ihr auch gar
nichts passiert und das wenn irgendwas
gedroppt wird auch wenn es nur ein Apfel
ist den wir tatsächlich langsam sogar
benötigen am zweieinhalb Hunger können
schon verloren dass wenn irgendwas
gedroppt wird das ist einfach auch
wirklich auf unsere Insel landet hier
vorne kann ich das auch noch mal eben
kurz ein bisschen schöner machen Zack
und da wird natürlich auch nachher dann
noch mal Erde hinkommen ich meine wir
haben da hinten noch fast allen Inseln
noch ein bisschen Erde die wir mitnehmen
müssen jedoch ähm haben wir tatsächlich
für heute immer noch die Mission Monster
fahren ich werde das jetzt mal abzählen
ich würde mir am liebsten eine Fackel
mitnehmen ich kann erstmal diese
Challenge eben kurz machen und zwar 20
steindruckplatten habt ihr die
Challenges hatte jetzt
[Musik]
10 steindruckplatten entschuldigung ich
habe es falsch vorgelesen ihr findet die
Challenges auch unten in der
Beschreibung verlinkt und ihr könnt auch
einfach googeln also ich denke mir nicht
die Challenges aus wir haben hier noch
Zaun Zäune für heute habe ich mir
vorgenommen 20 Zäune 20 Zoll Tore 20
Leitern und zehn Schilder die Leitern
könnte ich theoretisch jetzt schon mal
machen ich brauche dafür nämlich ein
bisschen Holz und dann muss ich das Holz
zu äh Sticks machen und dann schauen wir
mal reicht das schon nee das sind nur
neun Leitern ich brauche insgesamt 20 so
machen wir mal ein bisschen weiter 24
reicht das
nee das sind 18
okay machen wir zack
reicht das jetzt oder sind das dann nur
19 ja okay wir haben zack auch die 20
Leitern Challenge haben wir abgehakt ich
weiß wenn ich was mit diesen ganzen
Sachen soll 21 Leitern Mangroven
Druckplatten ziehen steindruckplatten
aber das wird schon da vorne haben wir
neue Setzlinge das heißt wir könnten
theoretisch auch ich weiß ich will ja
hier so ein bisschen die
holzdings machen wo war denn der andere
oder habe ich den schon eingesammelt
ich habe den habe ich gerade schon
eingesammelt hey wir wollten eigentlich
hier so ein bisschen die Bäume
anpflanzen die Sache ist jedoch dass ich
glaube das ist einfach nur Sinn macht
wenn ich jetzt sowas wie bei diesem
Mango Ding auch bei normalen Bäumen noch
mal eben mache kann ich die nämlich auch
so ein bisschen versetzt hier vorne
hinsetzen dann setze ich nämlich hier
noch mal so einen anderen Baum hin so
zack zack zack zack zack hier eine Eiche
und dann haben wir hier eins zwei drei
vier fünf Platz sollte passen 1 2 3 4 5
zack hier vorne noch eine Druckplatte
hin zack ein hoch und hier noch mal ein
Eichen Setzlingen dann haben wir die auf
jeden Fall hier auch schon mal gebaut es
sieht zwar wirklich nicht schön aus ich
habe mir das auch alles ein bisschen
anders vorgestellt aber wir brauchen
wirklich Holz wir müssen vorankommen und
dann nehmen wir zur Not auch mal einen
groben kein Holz
wenigstens etwas hier vorne bei euch das
Ganze weiter wir werden das ja auf Dauer
eh noch mal so ein bisschen größer
machen und dann tatsächlich auch die
Mauer die sich hier gerade befindet auch
abreißen weil ich das hier alles wieder
etwas größeren Fläche machen möchte wir
haben ja gerade so eine Art
schlauchhimmel oder weniger so kümmern
uns jetzt allerdings erstmal hier drum
wir können das Abbauen und wir haben nur
ein sag mal war das vielleicht doch noch
nicht fertig da vorne sind allerdings
noch ein Apfel und Stöcker gedroppt mal
schauen ob da auch noch irgendwas
rauskommt den Apfel kann ich direkt
schon mal eben kurz essen dann haben wir
so ein bisschen die hungerkeulen auf
jeden Fall schon mal aufgebraucht bzw
aufgepumpt äh hier vorne haben wir gar
nichts mehr was wir jetzt irgendwie
gerade benutzen können von daher können
wir jetzt noch zum Hauptziel kommen ich
habe 750 Bruchsteine ich immer noch ein
paar Stufen mit ich hoffe allerdings
dass das erstmal reichen sollte denn wir
kümmern uns jetzt ein bisschen um diese
Monster fahren ich habe ein bisschen
Angst weil es gerade
Nacht ist nicht ich mache mal kurz die
timelapse
ich bau noch mal Holz ab Steine ab mach
währenddessen eine timelapse und dann
machen wir die Monster farmens Tag wird
weil ich das da jetzt irgendwas ach komm
scheiß auf Noris noch von 29 30 Blöcke
sind das jetzt
dementsprechend würde ich diesen Block
hier einfach jetzt mal ab hier ersetzen
durch die
normalen Bruchsteine damit ich etwas
bauen kann ich kann noch die Buchstaben
hier drauf packen dann sollte das denke
ich auch funktionieren weil die sind ja
trotzdem auf einer gleichen Höhe oder
checken die Mops das auch das hier
normale Steine sind ich teste das jetzt
erstmal so vielleicht spont der hier
schon etwas und äh werde jetzt hier auch
einfach mal das ganze schon mal so ein
bisschen erweitern und dann alles was
hinter mir ist abbauen in diesem ganzen
Weg brauchen wir nicht mehr ich lasse
das jetzt erstmal so stehen ich werde
die Erde jedoch mal kurz sichern das
heißt wenn ich sterben sollte also wenn
schon die ersten Monster spawnen sollten
dass ich dann zumindest jetzt nicht
irgendwie Erde oder Holz oder keine
Ahnung was verliere nämlich erstmal nur
das hier mit und euch eine ganz kurze
timelaps noch mal wie ich da hinten den
Rest von dem welche abbauen werde
[Musik]
so meine Damen und Herren ich habe den
Weg jetzt bis hier vorne hin abgebaut
dass dahin ist auch die Spawn glaube ich
also zumindest würden wir sonst ja noch
was sehen da hinten hier ist gerade
nichts drauf gespannt zum Glück weil
sonst werde ich ein bisschen am Arsch
gewesen allerdings werde ich das ganz
sicher jetzt auch mal so ein bisschen
hier einfach
ja aufstocken so das wäre so ein
bisschen mehr Platz wir haben bei der
Monster fahren und die Monster einfach
mehr Platz haben zum spawnen ich bin
generell gespannt wie das jetzt hier
alles weiterhin laufen wird weil wir
natürlich jetzt so langsam voran kommen
in diesem Projekt also wir haben heute
natürlich schon einige challenges
gemacht allerdings auch in der Hinsicht
Ästhetik geht es langsam voran bzw in
der nächsten Folge zumindest wirklich
wirklich weil ich habe mir für die
nächste Folge vorgenommen dass ich
hinten zu fichtenholzinsel gehe und mir
wirklich mal diesen Baum da hinten
vornehme
weil ich brauche dieses Holz weil eine
Challenge ist ja auch noch dass wir uns
ein Haus bauen und das will ich halt
hier vorne auf unserer Hauptinsel machen
und das will ich halt ein bisschen mit
Fichtenholz machen ich muss da dann
natürlich erstmal was ganz ganz kleines
als Haus bauen ne also nicht dass ihr
jetzt hier irgendwie große Erwartungen
habt irgendwie Minecraft mit Luca
Staffel 1 mäßig dass ich da irgendwie
direkt so ein schönes Häuschen Bau aber
zwei Etagen keine Ahnung was das wäre
auch einfach too much das brauchen wir
gar nicht das ist so wie wenn du eine
Frau hast und ein Kind aber du brauchst
schon irgendwie sieben Kinderzimmer oder
so nach dem Motto den Platz benötigen
wir nicht und äh wir haben auch gar
nicht so viele Items oder so viele
Sachen die wir da irgendwie lagern
müssen wir wurden auch das hier unten in
die Kommentare geschrieben von wegen
Luca bau doch unter deine Insel eine
zweite Plattform um schlichtweg jetzt
fehlen mir noch so ein paar Buchstaben
Stufen um einfach da unten vielleicht
auch so einen kleinen Verstauraum zu
machen so ein bisschen Kisten rein fand
ich sehr sehr coole Idee werde ich auch
denke ich machen ähm dass man irgendwie
so eine kleine falsche macht mit einer
Wendeltreppe dann kann man eine Etage
runtergehen dann sind da drunter so ein
paar Kisten und vielleicht die ganzen
Werkzeug Sachen und dass das alles
gesichert ist die Sache ist allerdings
dass ich da aktuell noch kein Bedarf für
habe und ich will auch erstmal ein Haus
bauen er soll ja perspektivisch so
fortlaufen dass wir hier alles voll
haben mit Erde die wir uns in der
nächsten Folge von den anderen Inseln
holen werden und dann alles hier so ein
bisschen schöner machen erstmal und
schauen wie viel Erde wir haben wie weit
wir gehen können allerdings ähm ja genau
brauche ich erstmal noch ein paar
bruchsteinstufen werde die dann gleich
da vorne hinsetzen dazu bei der ich euch
jetzt auch nicht extra hier eine neue
timelaps einer muss ich nur eben kurz
glaube ich 9 oder 12 ich glaube 9 von
dem Bruchstein sollten direkt schon
reichen das heißt noch drei der ist
verbrannt perfekt der ist nicht
verbrannt noch zwei und der letzte zack
die packen wir jetzt eben kurz rein
bekommen dadurch ah Komma drei hätten
auch gereicht bekommen dadurch sogar 18
Buchstaben und können jetzt hier vorne
unsere Monster fahren so einen dicken
größer machen die Sache ist jetzt jedoch
dass wir das in der heutigen Folge auf
jeden Fall nicht mehr austesten können
denn die Sonne geht schon unter aber
hier sollte jetzt eigentlich etwas bauen
denn es sind auf jeden Fall 30 Blöcke
entfernt also man sollte nur 24 30
gemacht einfach auf Safe und es ist eine
normale Plattform auf einer normalen
Höhe also auch nicht auf der zweierhöhe
deswegen würde ich sagen haben wir auch
die monsterfarmen erledigt
ich hätte heute gern noch 10 Schilder
gemacht 20 Zäune und 20 Zaun Tore
allerdings haben wir dennoch 5
challenges geschafft und zwar die
Monsterfarm die Leitern die Stein und
holzdruckplatten und die zehn Bruchstein
Treppen es ist kein weiterer Baum
gewachsen allerdings haben wir da vorne
noch welche angepflanzt ich kann noch
mal eben kurz einen weiteren Mann
grobenheim Setzling Keimling keine
Ahnung wie das Ding heißt er hier
anpflanzen machen wir eins zwei drei
vier fünf Abstand können wir sagen damit
sie vorne riskieren nee das hat ich
lasse es ich lasse es wir haben schon
wir haben genug geschafft für heute
Aufnahme bei 50 Minuten wir ähm müssen
jetzt leider einfach noch mal ein
bisschen weiter abwarten aber das wird
schon auf Dauer wir kommen zum Ziel in
der nächsten Folge gehen wir zu der
Fichtenholz hinten bauen unser Haus und
bauen das hier alles so ein bisschen
weiter aus und dann mache ich vielleicht
doch einfach mal direkt zu Beginn der
nächsten Folge bis sie die Bäume wachsen
das machen wir
oder kann ich das machen wegen der
Monster Farm ich weiß nicht nicht dass
ich hier timelapse mache und dann kommen
die Monster ist auch egal wenn es euch
gefallen hat lasst einen Daumen hoch und
ein Video da abonniert meinen Kanal und
klickt auf die Glocke um weitere Teile
Skyblock und du gar nicht zu verpassen
schreibt mir bitte weiterhin Tipps und
in die Kommentare ich bin sehr sehr doll
auf euch angewiesen und wir hören uns in
paar Tagen
mann ich will dass irgendwas passiert
aber wir sind gerade immer noch im
abwarten Modus leider egal haut rein
macht's gut
[Musik]
[Applaus]